c'est une normale que Jeannette puis
José leurs impôts à 44% puis que les
autres les milliardaires qui se
promènent en hélicoptère dans notre
provinceau tant pis
très peu ou le moins possible cette
semaine on vous parle d'une des familles
les plus riches au Canada qui a placé
ses revenus loin à l'abri de l'impôt
pendant qu'ici elle ne sait pas gênée
pour demander des centaines de millions
de dollars en subvention au gouvernement
pour ces entreprises
[Musique]
une fuite nous révèle comment elle
multiplier les stratagèmes au Bermudes
pour minimiser ses paiements au Trésor
public canadien
c'est comme de dire qu'on respecte le
droit des femmes en Arabie Saoudite ici
Marie Maude Denis bienvenue à enquête
bienvenue au Nouveau-Brunswick le
royaume la famille Irving des stations
services aux quatre coins de
l'Atlantique et dans l'Est du Québec la
plus grosse raffinerie de pétrole au
Canada
l'exploitation forestière de plus d'un
million d'hectares de terre publique et
des papiers qui approvisionnent le reste
du pays en plus d'un énorme chantier
naval dans la province voisine la
fortune des earving est évaluée à plus
de 8 milliards de dollars c'est l'une
des familles les plus riches au Canada
et l'une des plus influentes dans les
Maritimes
ont créé cette richesse là pour moi ce
qui me frustre c'est que des entreprises
et grandes corporations vont tout faire
pour payer le moins d'impôts possible
pour participer le moins de notre
société que possible
[Musique]
derrière l'image d'un puissant
conglomérat qui fait la pluie et le beau
temps au Nouveau-Brunswick se trouve à
des centaines de kilomètres la face
cachée de l'Empire earving univers
secret ou pendant des décennies les
impôts se sont volatilisés comme par
magie dans le paradis fiscal des
Bermudes
[Musique]
sur les terres d'une coopérative
agricole de Rogers ville au
Nouveau-Brunswick le fermier Kevin
Arsenault cultive des légumes
biologiques mais son parcours va aussi
l'amener à faire le saut en politique où
il deviendra une épine au pied de la
famille
c'est une grosse grosse partie de notre
économie
c'est très difficile
de faire quoi que ce soit sans envoyer
de l'argent vers les
[Musique]
qui a été raffinée à Saint-Jean après ça
pendant que tu t'en vas travailler tu
vas rencontrer des transports medelines
qui est ring tu vas aller acheter ton
bois pour faire un projet de
construction c'est les magasins à Kent
au Nouveau-Brunswick qui vend les
produits de ring dans les séries de ring
qui sont coupées par ering sur les
terres de la Couronne
[Musique]
tu vas passer à côté de l'usine à papier
toilette ou tu vois utiliser le matin en
se réveillant
[Musique]
pourquoi ce fi au papier hygiénique
Royal
haut et fort qu'en achetant leurs
produits les consommateurs appuient des
compagnies canadiennes chez Royal on est
canadien jusque dans nos fibres royales
fièrement canadiennes
[Musique]
et leurs entreprises se tarent d'être
fierment canadien il pense sous silence
des décennies de recours au paradis
fiscaux
dès 1968 le patriarche de la famille
kennetherving a choisi le paradis fiscal
des Bermudes pour y incorporer des
sociétés de portefeuille détenant les
entreprises canadiennes du conglomérat
le taux d'imposition des sociétés au
Bermudes et nuls
[Musique]
puis en décembre 1971 Evin qui est
soudainement Canada pour s'installer
plus de temps après au Bermudes son
départ survient quelques jours avant
l'entrée en vigueur de l'impôt fédéral
sur le gain en capital et d'un impôt sur
les droits de succession au
Nouveau-Brunswick
[Musique]
est un pionnier parce qu'il est un des
premiers à
s'essayer à la gestion offshore à
transférer
manifestement
l'administration de tout son groupe
d'entités obermudes de façon à gérer ses
actifs à l'abri de toute surveillance
étatique et surtout à l'abri du fils le
professeur Alain Denault habite dans la
Péninsule acadienne il a publié de
nombreux ouvrages sur les paradis
fiscaux vous pouvez accentuer au maximum
des stratagèmes comptables qui
consistent à inscrire artificiellement
inouï
dans des contes ou Bermudes à travers
des structures que vous aurez créé l'un
des structures souvent factices
d'accord
[Musique]
un avocat Canadien a répertorié à
l'époque une dizaine de sociétés dans
les paradis fiscaux liés au eurving dont
la harving California old company
surnommé Earth care un des stratagèmes
fiscaux employés par les vignes de les
années 70 consistait à faire l'achat de
pétrole brut extrait en Arabie Saoudite
par la stand uder mais plutôt que de
faire l'achat de manière directe la
transaction passait par l'entremise 2F
Carl la société des Bermudes contrôlée
par les ring et leur partenaires
américains Carl acheter le pétrole de
standard à bas prix pour le revendre a
pris plus élevé à la raffinerie
canadienne des profits étaient donc
réalisés au Bermudes les bruits d'impôts
oui je raffine à mort mais regardez
toutes les factures que je reçois de
cette entité sœur au Bermudes qui était
tellement cruel avec moi regarder toutes
les factures salées qu'elle m'envoie je
suis bien obligé de les honorer et puis
je déduis ça de mes comptes
il ne voulait pas payer un tour
relativement élevé d'impôt sur les
sociétés au Canada ou aux États-Unis
pour eux c'est logique d'un point de vue
économique mais ça prive les autorités
canadiennes et américaines de revenus
fiscaux qu'ils auraient normalement
obtenu
ce stratagème a attiré l'attention du
fisc qui leur a réclamé plus de 140
millions de
dollarsing ont contesté et gagné devant
les tribunaux
aux règles au début des années 90 afin
de mettre fin ce que les autorités
fiscales canadiennes considéraient comme
de la vue
est mort en 1992 la fortune familiale
s'accumulait dans des fiducides toujours
au Bermudes dans les bénéficiaires
étaient ces trois fils John James et
Arthur et leur descendants mais
l'étendue de leur recours au paradis
fiscaux est un secret qu'ils ont
toujours bien gardé de génération en
génération
Kevin Arsenault tente de percer ce
secret des earving depuis plusieurs
années en 2018 il s'est fait lire sous
la bannière du Parti vert provincial
il a profité de ce nouvel tribune à
l'Assemblée législative pour interroger
le ministre des Finances au sujet des
[Musique]
est-ce que le ministre une liste
d'entreprises au Nouveau-Brunswick qui
ont de l'argent dans les paradis fiscaux
qui pratiquent l'évitement fiscal
est-ce que le ministre par l'entremise
du président
ils sont départements peuvent me dire
est-ce que la compagnie eurving fait de
l'évitement fiscal oui ou non
aucun dossier sur la plus importante
d'entreprise sur son territoire dont on
sait d'une manière notoire que depuis
plus de 50 ans elle pratique les
vêtements fiscal ce qu'elle admet
elle-même on s'en soucie pas
le gouvernement plaide donc l'ignorance
mais nous avons trouvé de nouvelles
pistes grâce à une fuite de documents
confidentiels avec notre collègue
Jacques poitrin de CBC à Frédéric thund
qui a écrit un livre sur les rings nous
avons fouillé dans les peurs une fuite
de documents provenant de paradis
fiscaux qui a été partagé avec le
consortium international des
journalistes d'enquêtes et Radio-Canada
nous y avons découvert près d'une
dizaine de sociétés des earving dans des
paradis fiscaux dont l'existence n'était
pas connue publiquement auparavant comme
la société FMA
donc cette campagne de FMA dans toutes
tes recherches tu l'avais jamais vu
jamais entendu parler de FMA avant
la fuite révèle que FMA est une société
d'assurance que les ring ont fait
incorporer ou Bermudes en 1973 afin
d'assurer les navires de leur compagnies
forestière canadiennes c'est ce qu'on
appelle une société d'assurance captive
sont des sociétés qui permettent à des
groupes de s'assurer eux-mêmes on
négocie avec soi-même on peut imaginer
que les conditions sont avantageuses le
ridicule saute aux yeux du moment qu'on
prend conscience du fait que pour
arriver à une opération comme ça il faut
la
signer dans un paradis fiscal
[Musique]
selon les documents confidentiels cette
société n'avait pas d'employé au bureau
l'adresse de FMA était en fait celle du
cabinet d'avocats à Paul bi au Bermudes
un cabinet spécialisé dans les services
offshore la fuite contient les états
financiers de FMA de 1974 à 2001 pendant
cette période FMA a accumulé plus de 13
millions de dollars en revenu net libre
d'impôts les primes que les compagnies
canadiennes de earving payaient à leur
propre compagnie d'assurance des
Bermudes étaient déductibles d'impôts au
Canada
c'est une façon simple pour une
multinationale canadienne de payer moins
d'impôts parce qu'il s'agit d'une
dépense au Canada qui réduit vos profits
ici mais qui augmente ceux de votre
société au Bermudes ou les impôts sont
nuls
la compagnie jay-zing qui gère la
division forestière de l'Empire eurving
a décliné notre demande entrevue par
courriel elle dit avoir cessé d'utiliser
la société FMA pour assurer ses navires
il y a plus de 10 ans et affirme que
c'était une bonne approche pour réduire
les coûts
même si c'est légal ça revient toujours
à cette question là pour moi c'est du
éthique si tu normales que Jeannette
puis José leurs impôts à 44% puis que
l'autre les milliardaires qui se
promènent en hélicoptère dans notre
provinceau tant pis
ou en pays très peu ou le moins possible
c'est du vol c'est du vol c'est du vol
des néobrons de notre bien commun de nos
infrastructures de nos écoles de nos
hôpitaux c'est ça qui
ça vient me chercher ça me va
après la pause une histoire de papier de
toilette qui met le député qui avait
Arsenault en furie
si vous voulez pas participer au bien
quand même du nouveau branding sortez
sacré votre carte je m'en fiche
il faudrait pas oublier qu'un vigne a
décroché une grande part d'un des plus
gros contrats publics de l'histoire
canadienne c'est la construction de ces
fameux navires de guerre pour la marine
dont les coûts explose on a pris la
semaine dernière qu'ils ont fait tripler
et que la facture s'élève maintenant à
85 milliards de dollars ce qui n'a pas
empêché un vigne de cogner à la porte
des gouvernements pour réclamer de
l'aide financière
[Musique]
possède aussi des chemins de fer au
Nouveau-Brunswick et quand c'est le
temps de les moderniser ils savent à
quelle porte frapper
en mai dernier le milliardaire
jimmerving lundi
héritiers de l'empire familial était aux
côtés du ministre fédéral des transports
pour recevoir une subvention de 21
millions de dollars
en plus d'être parmi les pionniers
d'évitement fiscal au Canada learvings
sont assez maîtres dans l'art de
recevoir des fonds publics
par exemple une réduction de la taxe
foncière d'une valeur de 112 millions de
dollars pour leur part métallique
[Musique]
une augmentation de 20% des terres
publiques de la province que la
compagnie peut exploiter
une subvention de 260 millions de
dollars de la nouvelle école pour les
aider à décrocher le lucratif contrat de
construction des navires de la Marine un
des plus gros contrats publics de
l'histoire canadienne
c'est facile de démontrer après ça
qu'une entreprise a besoin plus d'argent
pour pas perdre les jobs et qui ont
toujours le gouvernement
par la cravate
en avril 2020 pendant que la pandémie de
covid 19 bat son plan le député du Parti
vert Kéven Arsenault reçoit un courriel
inattendu la compagnie jay-reving
adressé à tous les députés de la
province learving promettent que pour
chacun des députés ils feront un don à
des refuges et des maisons de transition
un don de papier hygiénique royal
chercher du papier toilette partout puis
que les autres ont une compagnie de papy
toilette ils décident
de s'essuyer c'est ça c'est une zone
c'est ça
qu'on a à vous offrir maintenant j'ai
trouvé ça insultant c'est refuge là et
d'autres endroits qui vient en aide aux
gens sont sous financés au
Nouveau-Brunswick sont gravement
sous-financés
[Musique]
pendant ce temps-là leurs entreprises y
compris leur usine de papier Royal ont
réclamé des subventions nous avons
découvert que la compagnie jay-zerving a
reçu 12 millions de dollars en
subvention d'urgence pour les employeurs
touchés par la covid
[Musique]
moi dans ma tête c'est bien c'est un ou
l'autre vous pouvez pas avoir le beurre
puis l'argent du beurre vous pouvez pas
éviter de payer des impôts et en plus en
récolter
Kevin Arsenault propose alors que le
gouvernement provincial s'attaque aux
entreprises qui font de l'évitement
fiscal
si
vous avez pas assez dit
pour payer votre juste de port
et de participer au service public et au
bien commun de notre province vous
recevrez pas une mauvaise de scène du
gouvernement si vous voulez pas
participer au bien commun du
Nouveau-Brunswick sortez sacrez votre
camp je m'en fiche
réplique dans une lettre adressée au
chef du parti de Keven Arsenault ils
affirment que le conglomérat jdring a
toujours payé tous les impôts dus au
Canada que leurs entreprises ne sont pas
détenues et contrôlés depuis les
Bermudes et qu'elles sont possédées et
gérées par des Canadiens
je pense que cette déclaration a été
rédigée avec soin il nous disent la
vérité ces entités sont probablement
détenues par des Canadiens mais sa
masque le fait qu'il y a dans leur
structure plusieurs sociétés dans des
paradis fiscaux
nous avons toutefois constaté que toutes
les sociétés des ring au Bermudes que
nous avons identifié ont été dissoute au
cours des 10 dernières années
learving ont décliné nos demandes
entrevues lorsqu'ils ont empoché la
subvention pour leur chemin de fer notre
collègue Jacques Poitras a tenté
d'obtenir des réponses de jimmering
l'Empire mi sur pied par le patriarche
canutherving a été scindé entre trois
clans familiaux il y a une douzaine
d'années
la partie est maintenant entièrement à
Arthur ring qui lui aussi décliner nos
demandes entrevues mais par courriel sa
compagnie affirme que l'ensemble de la
structure de propriété de Ringway est
entièrement imposable au Canada
je crois que c'est très peu probable les
probabilités sont nulles je suis certain
qu'il pète tous les impôts qui sont dus
au Canada mais il s'assure que ce
montant est très faible
[Musique]
nous avons trouvé un dernier indice
important en consultant les états
financiers d'une division de vénal en
Irlande le document révèle que l'ultime
propriétaire de harving well est une
fiducie appelée
sont les initiales de Arthur urving
selon la fuite et Paradise papers cette
fille du SI a été constituée au Bermudes
depuis plus de 50 ans learving n'ont
donc jamais cessé d'avoir recours au
paradis fiscaux
[Musique]
permettent aux multinationales qui
utilisent les paradis fiscaux d'éviter
de payer une partie de leurs impôts
Canadiens
les lois ont été conçues ainsi
c'est donc l'histoire des ring mais
c'est vraiment une histoire de politique
publique
de piller notre bien commun et on
légalisé le processus si tu veux
légaliser pourquoi est-ce qu'on le
referme pas c'est réformes ses règles ou
ça craint
es
et de solliciter des fonds publics
selon le ordre ac/dc ils ont demandé une
subvention de 300 millions de dollars au
gouvernement fédéral pour moderniser
leur chantier naval qui construira les
navires de la Marine
[Musique]